from south korea down to australia a
surge of new covet 19 cases fueled by
the highly infectious delta variant has
governments scrambling to respond
australia's capital camera entered a one
week lockdown the city reported its
first locally transmitted case in more
than a year in the australian capital
territory a.c.t
this decision is as the result of a
positive covert 19 case in the territory
a case has been infectious in the
community
we also have positive wastewater
detections around the oct
two of australia's largest cities sydney
and melbourne are also seeing high
infection rates despite weeks of being
locked down
for the first time in the pandemic south
korea posted more than 2 000 new daily
cases earlier in the week
it led to a plea from the government for
people not to travel this upcoming
holiday weekend
if we don't stop coronavirus won't stop
either i would like to say to the public
that we ask you to refrain from
traveling to stay at home during this
liberation day holiday
as many of the new cases are outside the
heavily populated metropolitan seoul
area officials are concerned that those
returning to the city could bring covet
19 with them
this week the first of more than one
million rohingya refugees in bangladesh
started to receive coven 19 vaccines
20 000 infections and 200 deaths have
been recorded in the cox bazaar district
location of the refugee camps
we came here with happiness in our heart
we have received the shot after coming
here it's good to see that they are
treating everyone equally and managing
the process lawfully
the usually bustling streets of the
philippine capital manila reduced to a
trickle of traffic
only those with authorization can leave
their homes the government imposed the
heavy 14-day lockdown this week as like
many of the neighboring nations it works
to stem the rapid spread of new covet-19
infections and a spike in deaths from
the virus scott heiler al jazeera
bangkok